President Trump will hold a high-stakes
meeting tonight with China's president
this comes in a week of major foreign
policy challenges mr. Trump says he will
ask Jinping to crack down on North
Korea's nuclear weapons program the
summit follows the president's
condemnation of a chemical weapons
attack in Syria in a news conference
with the king of Jordan President Trump
called Tuesday's deadly attack on
civilians horrific major Garrett is at
the White House with mr. Trump's tougher
response major good morning good morning
Syria's murderous six-year civil war
presents a stark challenge for president
Trump's America first foreign policy
when the Obama White House last
contemplated a military strike on
humanitarian grounds mr. Trump wrote
stay away and fix broken us the question
can the president stay away now what
happened yesterday is unacceptable to me
President Trump said Wednesday the
chemical weapons attack in Syria that
killed nearly 100 people changed his
view on the conflict and the
dictatorship of Bashar al-assad when you
kill innocent children innocent babies
babies little babies with a chemical gas
that is so lethal people were shocked to
hear what gas it was that crosses many
many lines beyond a red line mr. Trump
also argued that if President Obama had
launched military strikes in 2013 in
response to the first confirmed mass
chemical attack under Assad things might
be different now I think the Obama
administration had a great opportunity
to solve this crisis a long time ago
when he said the red line in the sand a
red line for us is we start seeing a
whole bunch of chemical weapons Assad
crossed that red line in 2013 killing
more than a thousand people with sarin
gas
President Obama backed off after the
British Parliament failed to support a
military strike and Congress balked at
the time mr. Trump actually supported
staying on the sidelines saying
President Obama do not attack Syria
there is no upside longer-term status of
credit President Assad will be decided
by the Syrian
and as recently as last week Secretary
of State Rex Tillerson indicated Assad's
future would not be subject to
international pressure imagine if you
are that father and that is your child
who has just been gassed to death by a
regime you will never ever accept that
regime as your rightful leader Florida
Republican Marco Rubio implied Tillerson
statement gave the dictator license to
carry out this attack I believe that
that is an incentive to act with
impunity when I asked the president
yesterday if he was contemplating a
change in his Syria policy he said only
you'll see taken together the
president's remarks in the Rose Garden
suggested a possible shift underscored
Galle by the president's declaration
that on this and other matters he is
quote flexible all right we will see
thank you very much major